-Our next guest is
a Grammy Award-winning
singer, songwriter,
and producer
who is currently nominated
for six Grammy Awards,
including Producer of the Year.
His band Bleachers
will release their new
self-titled album on March 8th.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Jack Antonoff,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
How are you, my friend?
-I'm really good.
-That's great.
I'm glad to hear it.
-I'm fine.
-I want to talk to you
about stuff,
but first I -- and I don't
want to belabor this --
I want to congratulate you
on a few things.
You pointing at Fred?
-Yeah.
-Is Fred pointing at you?
I don't want to look.
[ Laughter ]
I have asked him --
I have asked him to stop.
Oh, boy. [ Laughs ]
You got married.
Congratulations.
-Yeah.
-Very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
August.
Do you feel like
you had enough...?
Like, I was hard knowing that
this was gonna pass so quickly.
Did you focus on the night?
Were you like,
"I'm gonna remember how great
this is the whole time?"
Were you present?
-I think it's for everyone else.
-Yeah. Interesting.
-And I think that's great.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Do you feel like as somebody
who performs for a lot of people
all the time,
you were able to be like,
this is just
a performance for them?
-That's what
I thought would happen.
-Yeah.
-And then...I...
was wrong.
[ Laughter ]
Someone told me --
you won't laugh at this --
that when you die
and when you get married
is the only time
everyone you love is in a room.
-Mm. Yeah.
[ Light laughter, murmurs ]
[ Laughter ]
They're like, "We're all dead!"
[ Laughs ]
And I was like,
oh, that's just a thing
someone says,
and I perform for a living,
so I don't mind
if the attention is on me.
And then as soon as it started,
my whole body became wet.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was really beautiful.
I'm looking for jokes,
but it was, like,
just really beautiful.
-I'm really glad.
It should be beautiful.
That is a perfect way
for it to be.
-My biggest takeaway is
this crazy emotional twist
when you....
We all have this, like, armor
that we wear, like,
"Oh, I'm bad at relationships,"
or I'm this or I'm that.
And then if you come
to a point in your life
where that just wasn't true...
-Yeah.
-...you have to do
so much unpacking of that.
-Yeah.
-That's a funny thing.
You know?
-Absolutely.
Where you're like,
"Oh, so it wasn't that.
It was a different thing."
-Yeah, It was just...
Yeah, I was just --
not time or whatever.
I don't know,
that's been the big thing
I'm focused on is sort of like,
oh, for all those years
I had all this mythology
and I just, you know,
it hadn't -- it just...
-Just hadn't met the right
person, that's all.
-You have a nice wife.
-I do.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I'll say this.
-You're the first person
who's had this much trouble
with Fred
being in their eyeline.
[ Laughter ]
-10 seconds to explain it?
-Yeah.
-Me, Fred, Andy Samberg,
Rick Moranis --
we're just a kind of person.
-Yeah.
-And...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's true.
-Yeah.
-So this must be great.
So, when you're in
the same room with him,
you do feel a need to be like,
"I'm here. You here?"
-I don't feel it,
but, like, other people...
Like, people on the street
will be like,
"You look like Fred Armisen."
And, yeah.
Or, like, "You" --
In a nice way.
It's great.
-The way...
The way you were making them
say it didn't sound nice.
I think, like,
on an aura level,
you also have a similarity,
in a very positive way.
I like both of your vibes a lot.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know what would be a really
a really funny thing
to do to you is, like,
when we put this on TV tonight,
edit in a empty drum kit.
-That would be funny. Yeah.
-So this whole time, like,
Fred isn't here
and it's like we're all,
like, humoring you.
[ Laughter ]
I also, just real quick...
-Sorry. It's about you.
I'm sorry.
-No, no, it's not about...
It's about you.
I feel like we've made this
about Fred, really,
if we're being honest.
-Yeah.
-But he, you know...
-He made that bed.
-He did.
-Sitting up there.
-Sitting up there
on his high horse.
-Yeah.
Bang, bang, splash, splash.
-Look at me, look at me.
Six Grammy nominations.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lana Del Rey album,
Taylor Swift album.
That's some very good work.
Congratulations very much.
-I'm really proud of those two
because I think in my industry,
like, there's this, like,
endless, like, rah-rah,
pivot this way and that way,
and I've had a few...
Really, Lana and Taylor,
we've just worked
for a long period of time
and, like, found this space
where it's like...
gets like loonier and loonier
and more exciting
and it just makes me feel...
And it's the same thing
with my band.
The record we just made, it even
ties into the marriage, too.
Like, I think a big theme
is, like, investing
in long relationships.
It makes me feel, like, sweet.
-And doesn't it also mean
that -- because, again,
there is, I think, a -- music
business has a reputation
as everything has to be
fraught and combative.
Do you feel like
you found yourself
in a place when you start
an album with somebody,
have a long relationship with
where you're like,
this just can be fun?
-Well, you know, making albums
is hard enough on the mind
and body that it seems like
an embarrassment to introduce,
like, dissonance
in the actual process.
-Yeah.
-It's almost like,
you know, we're fighting
something so much bigger,
so it seems so crazy.
It's like we're in a storm to,
like, figure out these things.
So it's so weird
that you would ever be like,
you know,
pick on the person next to you.
I always feel like that's
perpetuated by people who...
[ Sighs ]
You know, when I was younger
and I always wanted to do music,
people would always be like,
"Uh, well, that's a tough life."
And it's like, well,
it's all a tough life,
and it's also
a beautiful life.
And I wonder which
guidance counselors got together
and were like, "We're gonna
[bleep] on this job."
-Yeah.
-You know, 'cause like,
because it's not
even that weird.
It's not even like I want
to be, like, flying in space.
It's like, music is --
there's music everywhere,
and there's so many jobs
in music,
and there's music here and...
-Yeah, it's true.
If somebody walked into
a guidance counselor and said,
"I want to be an astronaut,"
they'd be like, "Great!"
-Exactly! But --
-Even though there's like
no astronauts.
-There's no jobs.
If someone wants to, like,
be an artist or work in music...
Somewhere along the way --
it might be ending,
but somewhere along the way,
there was this idea of, like,
"Let's get a plan B."
Or that even if you do it,
your life is horrible.
Everyone's always like, "I don't
know how you do the traveling."
And I'm like, "I don't know
how you do the [bleep] sitting."
Yeah, yeah.
-But you don't do that.
Try not to say that.
-I don't. Yeah.
-Yeah, good.
Leave that to Fred.
-Yeah.
-That's a classic Fred line.
Last time you were here,
we talked about
your collaboration
with Bruce Springsteen.
And then you did a show
across the street.
-Yeah.
-Radio City.
-Why didn't you come?
-You didn't invite me.
-Jimmy Fallon came.
[ Audience ohhs ]
He just showed up.
Sorry.
You can cut this part.
-No, leave it in. Leave it in.
I want them all to know!
[ Laughter ]
But this is amazing.
This photo makes me so happy
because I know how much...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...it means to you.
-The photo is really
speaking a truth
because I'm looking up
and just sort of...
Yeah, I see myself
being like, like,
"Thanks for the roadmap"
in the photo.
-Yeah. No, it is. It is.
You know, it's nice
because you are --
you are collaborating
in the photo as well.
Right?
It's not just like a worship.
You're actually
working together.
-Yeah.
-But it's like, I don't know,
it's like you're paying
a nice homage to him there.
-Well, I mean, he's obviously
one of the great poets
and musicians of our time,
but music comes
from a landscape.
I come from a place that --
New Jersey --
that is very misunderstood,
so you have to...
[ Laughter, cheers ]
Literally not a joke.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I guess the name
is a punch line.
But, you know, it's you --
you have to -- you need people.
And for me it was Springsteen
and the E Street Band,
it was Southside Johnny,
it was Saves the Day,
it was Lifetime,
it was, you know, Lauryn Hill.
There's all these things
that came out of New Jersey
that said, okay,
like, this place
that is so misunderstood
has a voice that...
And specifically with Bruce
in that writing, the landscape,
it's like, yeah,
it's what we do there.
We drive on highways and think.
And it gives you a lot of
courage to write and not,
um, just drive into the city
and pretend you're from there.
-That's fantastic.
It's a fantastic story you tell.
And I'm really happy for all
your great producing work.
It's really exciting
that Bleachers
has a new album,
and it's so exciting
you're gonna do a song
for us tonight.
-Yeah, first time
we're ever gonna play it.
-I'm very excited to hear it.
You guys, Jack Antonoff.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back with
a performance from Bleachers.